you might say that those are qualities
that you should look for in a minister
however if that Minister's behavior is
such that civil servants are simply too
afraid to work with them and we've had
reports of civil servants bursting into
tears before and after meetings with Rob
allegations uh of being sort of shouted
us and belittled and some reports of
civil servants actually being physically
sick because of the fear around dealings
with that Minister yes that is something
to consider in terms of where the
conservative party kind of is at the
moment it's a headache for what you see
now because his entire message as prime
minister was that he was going to bring
back integrity and transparency it's
very difficult to maintain that if you
get to lengthy report make it quite
serious allegations against Deputy Prime
Minister and then doesn't act however
Dominic Rob was one of his key
supporters that doesn't look great for
him either to lose his right hand man
like that
as you say it does really bring into
question lots of questions about Richie
sunx judgment because you know whether
or not he knew about these allegations
when he took Dominic Rob on that's
definitely going to be the next question
these are not new allegations not new
reports uh Dominic Robb obviously a lot
of this stuff happened but as alleged to
have happened when he was certainly in
Boris Johnson's government Russia United
is pretty much as soon as he became
prime minister reappointed him as
Justice secretary and indeed as Deputy
Prime Minister so giving him a role that
really shows he has confidence in in
Dominic Rob so there will be questions
about what he knew when what he was
informed of when uh and you know you you
have to remember that he lost Nadine
zahawi uh in in circumstances that were
in some ways embarrassing that he wasn't
aware of the disputes or he said he
wasn't aware when he appointed him so
again losing another Minister like this
it doesn't look good however keeping him
on if the report is particularly damning
that's a brings something that brings
its own challenges too
Rachel is it too early to talk about
possible successes if he does have to go
there are some names in the mix uh
Victoria Atkin uh Lucy Fraser Victoria
Apprentice he's our current attorney
general you'll notice those are all
women I think there is an understanding
that gender balance is something of this
particular cabinet isn't great at so
those are the names that are currently
being bloated I imagine that when it
comes to to filling this role which you
see that we want to make an appointment
very quickly he's had a number of months
to consider who might fill that role and
one would hope that he's done a bit of
vetting on all of those candidates so he
doesn't end up in the same position
again
I mean it is obviously enormously
exciting for for Westminster Watchers
and political journalists but do you
think the story has cut through with the
public especially
uh I think that there's so many
different news stories going on at the
moment and certainly
conservatives have been benefited
sitting in in recent weeks as indeed the
labor party has as well by the chaos
going on north of the Border in Scotland
with the SMP and I think both the main
Westminster parties have benefited from
looking rather competent in comparison
to that having a major ministerial
stacking or resignation if that is
indeed what happens does bring the focus
back to Westminster back to the Tory
party back to some of the chaos of the
Boris Johnson Liz truss era so it will
have an impact even if most of the
public don't particularly know or care
about Dominic rival that much
good point uh Rachel Campbell from the
new Statesman Burgers talk to you thank
you very much well our political
correspondent Amanda raycast is in with
me in the studio and Amanda just picking
up from what Rachel was saying there in
terms of what the public reaction to
this is of course we've got local
elections on the horizon as well so the
Prime Minister will will really want to
get this cleared up very quickly won't
he yes I think all of this mess really
harks back to that kind of the sense of
chaos that we had under Boris Johnson's
government and I think that she soon act
throughout has been Keen to kind of
argue that he's a clean broom that he's
going to have a government of a
professionalism and accountability
um Boris Johnson of course famously
didn't sack pretty Patel when
allegations of bullying were upheld
against her
um when they were investigated
previously
um and as we've been discussing he did
move quickly against Nadeem zahari and
indeed Gavin Williamson was forced to
resign quite quickly
um so I think up to now he has been
trying to show that he he can take quite
decisive action
um in cases like this but equally
Dominic Raab is a powerful figure in the
party he's a key Ally of Rishi sunak he
backed him throughout his leadership
campaign
um he was he's Deputy Prime Minister as
well as Justice secretary so if he does
decide to sack him
um that's that's potentially two posts
he has to fill we were hearing some of
the names there that could be appointed
in his dead but no prime minister really
wants to have a kind of cabinet
reshuffle just before a local election
it can cause all kinds of uh of of mess
really and Dominic Robb also someone uh
who is quite popular in the right of the
party so when he was previously Justice
secretary under Boris Johnson he was the
one that was leading the way and
attempting to get the UK out of the
European Court of human rights as
something which is very popular with the
rise of the party and something indeed
we've been talking about as the kind of
the foundation of this Rebellion over
the small boats registration so I think
of course we have to wait and see what
is in that report and I'm sure or
everyone in Westminster will be
scrutinizing it very carefully I think
unless he's completely exonerated it's
going to be quite a difficult call for
the Prime Minister and of course we know
it's going to be an extensive report
these eight different allegations
relating to his roles at three different
government departments over a period of
years some 24 different people it's
thought at least involved in this but we
wait to see what's in it Amanda thank
you we're going to break into this story
to bring you another breaking news let's
take you to Ukraine Secretary General of
NATO yen stoltenberg is visiting there
on a surprise visit he's speaking to the
cameras that's his name
or homes and hospitals playgrounds and
harbor stations
I think I visited the good shop and I
was deeply moved by what I saw there
Russian atrocities continues against the
Ukrainian people today
and those responsible must be held to
account
I also
laid a wreath at the wall of remembrance
of the Fallen for Ukraine
I pay tribute to all those who have lost
their lives or suffered wounds
seen or unseen in defense of their
Homeland
they will not be forgotten
Mr President I'm here today
with a simple message
NATO stands with Ukraine
we stood by you after Russia's illegal
annexation of Crimea in 2014
we stand by you today in your heroic
fight against
the Russian Invaders
and in defense of your country
and we will stand by you tomorrow
as you rebuild a work toward a brighter
future for the Ukrainian people
over the years NATO allies have provided
training for tens of thousands of
Ukrainian soldiers
and since last February NATO allies had
delivered more than
150 billion euros of support
including 65 billion euros of military
aid
this has enabled your troops
to force yourself out of Kiev kanson and
high keep
allies are now delivering more Jets
tanks and armored vehicles
a NATO's Ukraine fund is providing
urgent support
including medical supplies mobile
satellite systems and platoon Bridges
all of this is making a real difference
on the battlefield every day
we do not know when this war will end
but we know that Russian aggression is a
toxic pattern that must be stopped
we agreed on the importance of a just
unsustainable peace
and I strongly welcome
president zlenski's peace plan
we must continue to strengthening
Ukraine's Armed Forces
and we must ensure that robust powerful
arrangements are in place
for Ukraine's security
let me be clear
Ukraine's rightful place is in the
euro-atlantic family
Ukraine's rightful place is in NATO
and over time our support will help you
make this possible
today
the president and I discussed a
multi-year support initiative
this will help you transition from
Soviet era equipment and doctrines to
Nato standards an Ensure full
interoperability with the alliance
it is a testament to NATO's long-term
commitment Ukraine
NATO stands with you today tomorrow and
for as long as it takes
so president zielinski
thank you again for hosting me here
today I look forward to welcome you to
the NATO Summit in business in July
Secretary General speaking uh in an
unexpected visit to Kiev talking about
nature standing with Ukraine how they
just stood with them in 2018 when Crimea
was annexed by Russia he NATO stood by
them today and that they will stand by
them tomorrow as they build a brighter
future for the Ukrainian people and just
at the end they're talking about how
NATO wants to help Ukraine transition
its military from the Soviet era to the
NATO era and NATO stands with them today
let's bring in retired Air Vice Marshall
Sean Bell who joins me now from The
Newsroom Sean how significant is it uh
this visit in itself but also what he
just announced there about this military
transition from the Soviet era Jane I
think it was it was fascinating from a
military perspective I mean let's be
clear Ukraine is not in NATO it will
take quite some time for Ukraine to ever
meet the requirements to join NATO but
uh Han stolenberg was very very clear
that NATO is there to support and stands
firm with Ukraine he also talked a fair
bit about condemning the Russian
invasion but also preparing for the
future and it doesn't appear at the
moment that NATO is prepared to put
boots on the ground in Ukraine
ultimately nature is a defensive
Alliance and but a lot of the West is
providing Military Support but I think
the language here was that although
Russia will be paranoid about NATO
expansion and also about potential for
Ukraine to join NATO Helen stoneberg
could not have been clearer that by
Paving away in the future Ukraine will
have to be rebuilt currently it's core
infrastructure in the military is former
Soviet Union a former Russian kit but a
lower tier and almost certainly what
they're trying to do now is to offer the
potential for
um Ukraine's equipment to gradually be
brought up to Western standards bring up
the sort of technology and provide
Ukraine with its own credible military
capability as a transition to joining
NATO and that language up till now
there's always been some concern about
would Ukraine ever be able to join NATO
would it have to be remain in that
buffer zone to placate President Putin
and his Russia this was the first time
we've held this overt
statement from NATO Secretary General
that says we are planning for you to
join we're going to make it easier for
you to join and actually there's some
sunny out plans Beyond this so it was a
really important statement for for this
NATO Secretary General and really
important visit for him actually into
Ukraine itself
in terms of that first
it haven't really had one before because
of the concern over Russian reaction
what do you think Russian reaction will
be to this do you think President Putin
is sort of throwing something at the
Telly right now he will endowed to be
frustrated but let's be clear from a
grand strategic perspective the war is
not going well for President Putin he's
losing a hell of a lot of soldiers
grindingly slow progress in the dombas
and he will be paranoid about the impact
of the forthcoming spring offensive from
Ukraine and if you look at most of the
metrics he wanted to stop NATO expansion
you know
um finland's joined Sweden's on its way
and all of a sudden now you're talking
about Ukraine potentially joining that's
a crushing blow to his ambition it's
also evident that Russia is economy is
suffering so this will be very unwelcome
but what we have to be careful of here
and I'm sure NATO will be aware they've
got a finesse line here because they do
not want to play to the Russian
narrative that they are fighting NATO
because actually what they're doing is
fighting Ukraine and Ukraine is simply
using Western support of equipment to
fight that war they've got to be really
careful to finesse this to not play to
Pearson's narrative to potentially
expand this conflict if it actually
appears to be NATO fighting fighting
Russia
okay Sean Bell uh very good to talk to
you on that thanks very much just remind
you of that breaking story in the last
few minutes the NATO Secretary General
Jan stoltenberg has been talking in Kiev
talking about welcoming Ukraine into
NATO giving his first ever statement
that NATO would be welcoming Ukraine and
that NATO would like to help Ukraine
transition from their Soviet era defense
systems into those compatible with NATO
who says he would like to see Ukraine in
its rightful place in the euro-atlantic
family and in NATO and he said that NATO
stands with Ukraine now in the past
today and will stand with nato in the
with Ukraine in the future as they
rebuild their country the other breaking
news story of course that we will also
update you on is Dominic Robb the report
into his behavior has reached now the
prime minister's desk the prime minister
is now deciding what to do with that
report if there's any updates on that
we'll bring them to you as soon as we
can
but let's stay with what is happening in
Ukraine and the U.S ambassador at large
for Global criminal justice has told Sky
News that the Russian President Vladimir
Putin needs to be held accountable for
the Ukrainian children who've been taken
from their Homeland Beth Van Scott told
me that Russia is systematically moving
children out of Ukraine the latest
figures suggest more than 6 000 have
gone missing but she expects the number
to be far higher I started by asking her
how she'd Define what's happened to
these children
this is in essence a grave breach of the
1949 Geneva conventions which protect
members of the civilian population from
being forcibly deported or forcibly
transferred from territory during an
unconflict situation so these children
have been abducted essentially kidnapped
they've often been taken across an
international border and then have been
sent to very far-flung places within
Russia and subjected to whatever in
essence sham uh adoptions potentially
and so this is indeed the basis for the
two arrest warrants that were recently
issued by the international criminal
court against President Vladimir Putin
himself and Russia's children's
commissioner Maria levova biloba
Russia's saying that it's acted on
humanitarian grounds that it's
protecting the interests of children in
the area where military action was
taking place and it hasn't moved anyone
against their will why do you not
believe them well for one Russia's not
able to claim that they are doing this
for humanitarian grounds when they have
in fact created the humanitarian crisis
that put these children at risk in the
first place these children were in
civilian areas that came under Russian
attack so they Russia cannot turn around
and say they're doing this for
humanitarian purposes the reality is
these children have been taken they have
had their phones confiscated is our
understanding they're not able to
contact their loved ones Guardians
others who want them back and want to
know where they are they have not just
been taken to Safe places within Ukraine
but rather taken across an international
border and often taken to areas very far
from Ukraine the point of any sort of a
humanitarian evacuation that might be
allowed under the laws of war is that it
is temporary temporary and that it is
immediately reversed when the conditions
subside that caused the need to take
that and none of this has happened how
many children and families could be
affected here more than 6 000 children
who have parents Guardians loved ones
others who want them back have been
forcibly taken from Ukraine and are now
um gone essentially and are not
necessarily in touch with their loved
ones so that I have a feeling is a a
figure that is too low and I imagine
that is more open source information
emerges we will be able to add to that
figure and to show the full scope of
what Russia has done here with respect
to Ukraine's children six thousand is an
astonishing figure even if you